[Música]
desde 2015 un movimiento sin precedentes
ha arrasado los tribunales de todo el
mundo grupos de jóvenes querellantes
algunos de tan solo 7 años han demandado
a los gobiernos por su inacción para
combatir el cambio climático por ejemplo
en el invierno de 2018 25 jóvenes
colombianos incluidos jóvenes indígenas
demandaron al gobierno por ucir la
deforestación en el Amazonas y no
cumplir con sus promesas respecto al
clima esta demanda y otras más
argumentaba que las políticas
medioambientales destructivas ponían en
riesgo las vidas actuales y futuras de
los querellantes la pasividad ante el
clima viola sus derechos humanos básicos
específicamente el derecho a un medio
ambiente sano a los alimentos la salud y
el agua Pero qué tienen que ver los
derechos humanos con el medio ambiente
tienes derecho a respirar aire limpio
vivir en un mundo con rinocerontes
blancos osos polares y ranas hoja de
lemur Y qué hay del derecho a los
manglares y los arrecifes de coral el
primer documento internacional en
delinear los Derechos Humanos fue
adoptado por las Naciones Unidas en
1948 con dos guerras mundiales marcadas
por innumerables atrocidades y actos de
barbarie como telón de fondo este
documento conocido como declaración
universal de los Derechos Humanos O dudh
describe las libertades inherentes de
todas las personas independientemente de
Quiénes sean o donde vivan y que no
pueden concederse ni revocarse establece
derechos Como la libertad de pensamiento
libertades políticas como el derecho a
un juicio justo y derechos culturales y
socioeconómicos como el derecho a la
vivienda y la atención médica
adecuadas si bien la dudh en sí no es
vinculante su formación otorgó un
conjunto de normas y principios éticos
reconocidos internacionalmente y fue el
cimiento para la legislación de derechos
humanos y desde 1948 estas libertades se
han entretejido en tratados
internacionales constituciones y leyes
lo que significa que los países han
optado por respetarlas y
protegerlas como resultado incontables
luchas y movimientos por los Derechos
Humanos individuales han obtenido
legitimidad y una base jurídica para
buscar Justicia La dudh no hace mención
de la naturaleza la biodiversidad ni el
clima estos derechos en cambio primero
quedaron est a nivel nacional muchos
países del hemisferio sur a menudo
influidos por leyes y cosmovisiones
indígenas incorporaron a sus
constituciones y tratados regionales el
derecho a un medio ambiente sano
rápidamente Defensores de los Derechos
Humanos solicitaron en el resto del
mundo y a las Naciones Unidas que
también reconocieran este derecho muchos
argumentaron que los principios mismos
de la dudh dependen del acceso a
ecosistemas sanos cada año millones de
personas mueren contaminación del aire y
el agua la disminución de las
poblaciones de polinizadores amenaza la
seguridad alimentaria básica y la
pérdida de hábitats costeros ha dejado a
millones expuestos a riesgos mayores por
las inundaciones y los huracanes
destructivos proteger este derecho es
más urgente ahora que nunca antes el
cambio climático está causando olas de
calor más frecuentes sequías más
prolongadas e incendios forestales más
destructivos sin un cambio rápido y
significativo el planeta está en riesgo
de extinciones en masa lo cual podría
aniquilar un cuarto de la biodiversidad
del mundo para
2100 estas pérdidas para los ecosistemas
naturales podrían tener efectos
secundarios
catastróficos amenazaría aún más el
suministro de alimentos destruiría los
medios de subsistencia y dejaría a la
humanidad más vulnerable a las
enfermedades afortunadamente el impulso
va en aumento actualmente más de 150
países y jurisdicciones han consagrado
el derecho a un medio ambiente sano en
las legislaciones nacionales el 5 de
abril abr de 2018 la Corte Suprema de
Colombia falló a favor de los jóvenes
querellantes y determinó que el gobierno
está legalmente obligado a reducir la
deforestación y las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero para proteger los
derechos de las generaciones actuales y
futuras este caso y otras victorias
históricas similares de jóvenes en los
tribunales de los Países Bajos Alemania
y los Estados Unidos han inspirado a
otros a defender la causa al verano de
2023 una ola de más de 2000 demand
medioambientales basadas en los derechos
humanos se ha presentado en todo el
mundo y este número Probablemente crezca
en 2022 una inmensa mayoría de Estados
miembros de la asamblea general de la
ONU se unió para mantener los derechos
humanos alineados con un mundo cambiante
al reconocer el derecho a un medio
ambiente limpio sano y sustentable
reducir las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero detener la deforestación y
mantener limpios los cursos de agua
llevará a una cooperación mundial sin
precedentes estos casos judiciales son
un poderoso Primer paso para
responsabilizar a los gobiernos y
brindarles a las futuras generaciones
una mejor posibilidad de respirar aire
limpio y vivir en un mundo con
rinocerontes blancos osos polares y
arrecifes de coral en los aos por
venir a qué más tienes derechos solo por
estar vivo visita ed.ted.com your Rights
para conocer acerca de los Derechos
Humanos que compartimos y cóm su
protección universal nos ayuda a
asegurar la Libertad Justicia y paz en
el mundo